welcome back to cbs this morning the
number of reported coronavirus cases
around the world
has just topped 30 million the world
health organization says alarming rates
of transmission
can now be seen again in europe so that
brings new urgency
to the global search for this vaccine
holly williams is the first network
correspondent to see how one vaccine
candidate
would be produced for widespread use
holly good morning to you
good morning there are 36 vaccines for
covert 19
currently in human trials according to
the world health organization
and we were given rare access to a
facility here in the united kingdom
where a vaccine could very soon go into
production
this sterile production line could be
mass producing a vaccine against covert
19
within weeks right now they're training
staff
filling glass vials with water
they could start filling vials of a
covid vaccine here as
early as november maybe even before a
vaccine has been approved
and that's because as soon as they get
that final approval
they want to start sending it out to the
public these are unprecedented times and
require unprecedented initiatives
the world needs about seven and a half
billion
uh population to be covered managing
director of wakat uk
ravi lemay told us his facility can
produce up to
240 million doses of a new vaccine in a
year
but if the vaccine they start producing
here doesn't get approved for safety
they'll simply have to throw it out is
it a gamble is it a gamble to start
packaging up
millions of doses of a vaccine before it
has that final approval
i won't say it's a gamble i would say
this is investment in public health
the oxford vaccine arguably the front
runner in the race to stop the new virus
despite a recent pause in its trial will
likely be produced here
the u.s government has given more than a
billion dollars to the drug company
behind it
astrazeneca to secure at least 300
million doses
but the world's biggest vaccine
manufacturer which is based in india
warned this week that production is not
being ramped up quickly enough
and it could take until 2024 to produce
enough doses of vaccine to cover the
entire world
anthony holly williams in london thank
you holly